[Applause]  [Music]  what did I tell you I told you your boy  Pacquiao was gonna beat him right so she  was gonna beat him by knockout also told  you that Lucas mateesah was gonna quit  listen man I know this fight game and I  want you to understand certain things  the champion is always gonna be a  champion  Manny Pacquiao never quit never gave up  him when it's anything he was ever  stopped he was stopped by trying too  hard he was stopped by going in and  giving it his all Lukas Matisse a has  been stopped by not giving him his own  he has been stopped by quitting so once  you got it all gonna do it's over he's  here he's worthless as a fighter right  now because you can't get the best out  of him so I hope the payday was good  and I hope it was worth it manny  pacquiao no give you right now there's  no giving so every fight that you have  after that gonna be a rough one baby  combats all  [Applause]  [Music]